Oh Oh No
so behind the scenes of wizard battles
360
[Applause]
hi this is Nico I guess I just want to
walk right up it
oh let's get a little hike where are we
and what are we looking for we are
currently at SD village and we're
looking for a spot where two wizards can
battle each other with fireworks look
around here there's lots of great stuff
[Music]
[Music]
whoa whoa
Colorado was where the roman candles at
man you seen roman candles around here
Jake wants me to test out the Wardrobe
to make sure they are flame retardant to
not catch on fire on set where this
shoots on the other side but so
basically we're going to try with the
lighter to light a light a piece of it
to see if it goes up and it seems to be
burning pretty well it's okay better
whoa shoot it's good
[Music]
basically if we were in here using the
things we're going to use and there was
ground cover weeds dry brush we'd have
to have it cleared to accommodate the
State Fire Marshal here's something for
your camera this firing system this box
is from 1930 whoa and this was given to
you at MGM studios when you had to do a
bullet hit on the stage give you this
firing box the battery and the ordnance
for your shot this box fired 30 seconds
over Tokyo which won an Academy Award
for the owner and Logan's Run which won
an Academy Award for the owner
his name was Curley Paul Pollard this
one is what they call a nail board it's
is this also was built in 1930 and it
belonged to Fred Kramer who was head of
special effects at Paramount Studios for
50 years positive goes here the common
negative goes there and when you touch
it that's how we used to do machine gun
hit bang baby Mae Mae Mae Mae Mae Mae
anything positive negative
I like this part of it burled walnut and
these things are the innovators of the
firing systems we have today then I
carry a military this one will shoot 20
miles it's magneto 3 hitter 6 hitter you
hit that it goes off whatever it is
being that they're made custom by people
that know what they're doing are very
expensive but I'm dealing with people's
lives their bodies it has to be perfect
there is no excuse not to be perfect
with pyrotechnics there is no excuse the
most pyro I ever shot when talk with
Nick Cage about the navajo code speakers
in one shot the opening sequence of the
cave alley
we ran 135 thousand feet of wire just to
get from point A to point B my favorite
show Starship Troopers because of the
volume of pyro and also the storyline
one of the movies I'm proud of Tomorrow
Never Dies I was one of the few
Americans to ever work on a James Bond
film and I had a James Bond movie on my
goal list since 1976 and finally made
one in 2001 nice yeah came here two days
ago we plan things out we're a little
worried that we're gonna be too close to
the field it turns out that worry was
correct it won't be too close to the
field especially some of the newer
projectile fireworks we're going to be
using so we need to find a new spot it's
not close I feel because if a spark
lands in that field that field will go
up instantly I don't know if you guys
have heard about California wildfires
but it's pretty much oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] and it's done the old fields on
fire that quick we're trying to move
this location over to a new area the
thing is the camera can only see depth
it can only see like it can only create
3d depth up out to about 20 25 feet if
all our structure and our obstacles are
beyond that then you're not getting any
cool 3d effect trying to find a spot
still has space where we can circle each
other and fight and do all that kind of
thing without being too contained but
not
to open so it's a little tricky I think
we'll figure it out though well it's
about noon right now and we have a
couple things to do first of which plan
out the video because the fire marshal
came in and told us that all our
locations would not fly we need to pick
new locations for the whole piece and
rechoreograph everything and once we're
done with that we'll move into actual
like rehearsals thankfully the first
shots super easy and it doesn't really
require the pyro guys once three hits
we're gonna have about an hour per shot
why are we waiting till the end of the
day to film fireworks as we all know are
best viewed at night but in our case
it's going to be late afternoon /
evening that's mostly because the lower
position of the Sun will just kind of
make things a little dimmer ideally and
we'll make the fireworks in the color
stand out just a little bit more
shooting at night isn't really an option
though for us because the Odyssey rig is
after all made out of GoPros it's a
small window of filming it's not that
it's a medium window of filming so it's
a pretty write down the medium like
medium it's not that it's not tight but
it's not it's not relaxing
all right so I don't know we have too
much water for this truck poorly
maintained we will find out what's good
market here instead 192 inches one of
the nice things about being a producer
is that when you hire the right people
when you're on set you can just step
back and watch them work and enjoy your
Gatorade in the shade which is what I'm
doing right now resident doing
everything uh-huh okay listen I'm gonna
try man I'm not very good driver uh-huh
not very lipstick no sorry now we're
trying to back his truck up he hasn't
ruined it before it's not going
I have a feeling this break on is your
breakup your break might be on let's
make a break with you all right so we're
hitting crunch time right now things are
about to happen
big thing is I have put this camera down
and work on the sound to get a parking
place to water down the set after that
they'll probably be ready to set the
charges and explosions will happen
the GoPro rig a 360 rig has a special
mount and there's a special light stand
with that special mount the people who
packed up the light stand we're not
aware of that
still grabbed a regular lights and I
thought the special mount so now we have
to build our own new stand on the spot
on the day before we shoot our show
order digital or everything almost
always works the next step here then is
get the camera out yep powered out on
the batteries on it on it I'm going and
see how we can right there cool
[Music]
[Music]
how's the lizard sound um it's done yeah
yeah what is it
mmm-hmm it's Friday meaning the video
comes out Monday Scott from Germany
named Martin is really into spatial
audio 360 audio will you watch this
video you're gonna be able to look
around gonna be able to hear what you're
looking at most 360 videos on YouTube
don't have this a lot more interesting
to watch when the audio follows what
you're looking at as well yeah you'd
shout out to Martin really excited to
see how this video turns out wizards or
wizards all around me
wizards okay wizards all right it's
women and wizards one of the Wizards
swimming swimming all right